there's a woman who just showed up to
a a meeting in lewden county virginia
and she it was a school board meeting
and she gave
a fiery denunciation of
critical race theory in the words of
martin luther king jr i have a dream
that my four little children will one
day live a nation where they will not be
judged by the color of their skin
but by the content of their character
now i have a dream that we will
implement love
not hate or supporting another jim
crow's agenda crt is not an honest
dialogue is a tactic that was used by
hitler and the klu klux klan
on slavery's very many years ago to dumb
down my ancestors
so we could not think for ourselves crt
is racist it is abusive
it discriminates against one's color let
me educate you
an honest dialogue does not impress
oppress an honest dialogue does not
implement hatred or injustice
it's to communicate with deceiving
without deceiving people
today we don't need your agreement we
want action in the backbone for what we
asked for today to ban
crt we don't want your political
advertisement to divide
our children or belittle them think
twice before you indoctrinate such
racist theories
you cannot tell me what is or is not
racist look at me
i had to come down here today to tell
you to your face that we are coming
together and we are
strong this will not be the last greet
and meet
respectfully okay now
a lot of people are going to watch this
even conservatives even people who
oppose critical race theory
they're going to watch this or listen to
this and they're going to say oh well
i don't i don't agree with all of her
rhetoric oh well
i don't you know some of those
comparisons they're a little bit much
for me ah you know that this could have
been a little more articulate or this
could have been stated differently
i agree as we've just been talking about
i agree it's very important to be
precise
in our language and it's very important
to be aware
when of when people are not being
precise when people are just using
platitudes and things like that
it is also important to be politically
effective
the main takeaway i get from this woman
is kick critical race theory out of
schools
i totally agree with that she's
absolutely right
we need to join with her we need to
welcome anybody
who will oppose critical race theory it
is poison in schools
it is terrible for our politics it is
based on a lie it undermines our very
faculties of reason
you got to get rid of it so
well we can do two things at once you
often hear people say you can walk and
chew gum at the same time
we can improve our rhetoric we can be
aware
of the platitudes around us especially
from the left because those are the ones
being pumped in
from the schools from political race
theory actually from the big tech from
big corporate america from big
government from big administrative state
from everybody from big hollywood you
you can be aware of that and you can try
to call people's attention to that
and you can also engage in political
coalitions
to fight these things that woman i would
love show me the next time she's talking
at a school board i want to be there i
want to be there to applaud her
because she's absolutely absolutely
right about what we need
to do hey hey you
you got to ring the bell they don't like
it they don't like it here at youtube
when you ring the bell and you get
notifications
but do it do it anyway before they shut
us down ring the bell
subscribe like it we'll see you next
[Music]
time